what if I told you that as many as eight
point eight million unique viewers for
watching the same for tonight
competition every Friday and that it
wasn't even run by for tonight developer
Epic Games but mine unaffiliated
youtuber why hello there my name is
keemstar
and just recently epic pledge to sync a
hundred million dollars into the
upcoming season first thing the
fortnight World Cup sometime in the
future and in the eight-week fortnight
summer skirmish whether it's eSports or
not this [ __ ] is poppin off
[Music]
for tonight Friday answered one of the
big questions that everyone had when
fortnight exploded into mainstream
relevance just a few months ago how are
they gonna make this interesting to
watch
unlike other attempts at Battle Royale
esports fortnight fridays has placed the
emphasis on two things streamers and
kills excuse me the whole thing feels is
much like a reality show as it does a
major eSports event there's as much
focus on the means the highlight plays
and the spectacle that for a night has
become on Twitch as there is on who wins
and who loses
9:7 HP in a dream oh my gosh which is
probably where all the for tonight's not
an eSport cries are coming from but the
answer to that question doesn't really
matter the bottom line is that people
are competing and millions of eyes are
on them problem number one with Battle
Royale eSports is the logistical
nightmare with getting a hundred people
in a room physically or virtually to
battle to the death
the second big problem is how you make
that interesting for viewers without
boring them to death or giving them a
seizure this crazy I'm like how does
this brain think that fast what oh my
gosh look at say well popular youtuber
keemstar and UMG have done with
fortnight fridays is tune the focus of
their broadcasts away from the highest
years of competitive integrity and
towards action and entertainment here's
how it works
during fortnight fridays two teams of
two joined four-person squads and battle
it out the team with the most
eliminations moves on in the bracket and
every team must stream the matches to
ensure a competitive integrity and well
viewership numbers gone are the problems
with turtling up in one-by-one
structures and playing riskless
fortnight this format is about lafalot
yeah me
I had shot em with the most oh but watch
the edit play here 0:03 wanna save the
Tree of Life and the build the say from
72 hours extreme I mean look at this
versatility is built
[Music]
[Music]
but it's not just keemstar trying to
make the competitive side of fortnight
work for tonight's eSports origin story
starts in the same place that almost
everything important about for a night
starts from ninja ninja hosted his own
event Ninja Vegas at the eSports arena
in Las Vegas the event broken ninjas own
record for concurrent viewers on an
individual's push stream with six
hundred and sixty seven thousand
concurrent viewers at the time it wasn't
anything new in terms of format ninja
mostly just applied the pub G eSports
format the fortnight but like King star
does now he kind of an emphasis on
personality the event was about ninja
players even got a financial incentive
if they managed to kill up but a lot of
the on-screen broadcast time was spent
on other top streamers - like myth dr.
Lupo was even one of the casters Florida
has shown us that these on-screen
personalities are what keep viewers
watching after ninja Vegas came the e3
four night Invitational pro-am which
leveraged the fact that even celebrities
were caught up in the massive wave of
four-night culture and teamed them up
with pop streamers to compete and CD in
the third held up alive girlís the new
days pass it out pancakes the event was
our first opportunity to see fortnight
from a third-person perspective getting
to see build battles from afar without
having to deal with that spinning
first-person blueprint rollercoaster
ride we're all used to by and large the
event was successful widely viewed an
even relatively action-packed
and in storybook fashion ninja and DJ
marshmallow came out the victor
now for tonight Friday has been a
shocking success lil yachty Paul George
and marshmallow plated the Invitational
and obviously ninja Vegas was incredibly
successful so it's for tonight the
future of eSports well it hasn't all
been perfect let's get back to that
hundred million dollar investment epic
is making it's an exciting number sure
but the implementation of the for
tonight eSports framework has been
awkward
I cannot even move bro I could not even
move one more time oh my god the
fortnight summer skirmish is an eight
week long summer tournament series
that's happening every Friday and
Saturday this summer eight million
dollars in prize money is guaranteed
over the course of the event it sounds
great
right well even the first few weeks of
the event have been mired in mixed
reactions and severe technical problems
right now historic lows lagging I'm
still stuck in the zone are you kidding
um are you kidding dude I'm into
ikazuchi I couldn't get in this story
look how many people just died to the
zone epic hit the right tone by allowing
players to stream the tournament but
their viewer friendly eSports client
wasn't exactly ready for the start of
the season there was lag UI issues and
going back to that focus on survival
made the format just boring the summer
skirmish does offer a small incentive
for players who are able to get the most
kills but if we're being honest it
really only matters if you can get
victory warehouse it's simply about
staying alive and sometimes that's like
watching paint dry but for tonight
Friday never had that problem
I think at this point it's pretty hard
to argue that fortnight's not well on
its way to establishing itself but it is
easy to argue that there's a long way to
go pro players are literally trying to
queue up into a lobby all at the same
time in hopes of getting an effective
scrim and the game itself does
absolutely nothing to help competitive
players
there's no ranked mode no custom lobbies
nothing what we're seeing with 490
sports is honestly not that far from the
early days of of GE Sports where a
hundred players would load into a match
at the same time leading to overheated
machines and failed events the viewer
experience was challenging to say the
least
[Applause]
yeah at the center of it all seems to be
streaming for night has proven that you
don't need everybody all in the same
place to compete and that when it comes
to viewership personality and
accessibility are often just as
important as skill for night has also
proven that as much you want to watch
our favourite players win we also want
to be able to interact with them we want
to watch them style on people we want to
watch them fans and trash talk
[Applause]
we want to get to the heart of what
gaming is all about so it's for tonight
an eSport does it even matter that
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]